bir fayda Activity on tabis Elif ayt-tyt
Boş zaman bir aktivite itin aktiviteler
yani İffet saat aktivite ettin Boş zaman
aktiviteleri Das hobidi hobis hobiler
dersimizin konusu Boş zaman aktiviteleri
ve hobileriniz Hemen başlayalım
şüphelinin bir fiildir oynamak fiiline
oynarız Örneğin topla oynanan bütün spor
türleri için Shipping free kullanılır ki
ne normalde de oynadığımız karttır
Bilgisayar oyna da satranç gibi oyunlar
için yine şüphelinin fiili kullanılır
Ayrıca İngilizce'deki Play kelimesine
benzer olarak enstrümanları da şu pilin
yani çalmak olarak şüphelinin hileyle
kullanmamız lazım örnekle başlayalım
basket bağış planın spielen fili Düzenli
bir fiildir örneğini şişe
bu filmi çektim işbirli basketbol
buradaki nesneyi en sona koymayı
unutmayın ya da Hobi olarak ifade ederse
o zaman fiili çekmeyiz My hobbyist
basket baş pilin burada nesne ve fiili
en sona yazmamız lazım şüphelinin En
sonuna mastar halde gelir pos baş
pelinwood Düz cümle olarak filmini
çekeceğim neye göre zi yani onlar diş
pilin fos baldiş pil infuss bye mayın
hobi istf usbaş pilin My hobbyist fos
baş peeling Komplo taş bileş peeling
komple uta bilgisayar şu pile oyunlar
yani bilgisayar oyunu oynamak Bak eğer
speedcom Pilotaj Player HP
da tam komple Ota ikisi de aynı şey
İkisinden birisini kullanabilirsiniz My
Hobby is Computer spili Shipping in Şah
pilin yani satranç oynamak zi yani onlar
diş pilin şahıs planın şahmay hobbyist
Şah şu plinkett akış planın D muzika
kaşığı pirinç git ağı ımay hobbyist git
ağış pilum Town yani sürmek yani
tekerleği olan bütün araçlarla sağın
feneri kullanmam lazım ister paten olsun
ister arabayada bisiklet olsun sağ kat
yani bisiklet tâat sağ ıntown fiili
düzensiz bir fiildir Sen ve o derken
anın üzerine sadece 2
16 eklemeniz yeterli bir iş patladı
ispatla sağın fakat bakmayın hobi İst
fakat Farm
bu in-line afaan yani paten kaymak de
mantı zaman seyahatin Line a man Who
piasten Line a farm Bir de sadece fiil
olarak kullandığımız aktiviteler vardır
bunların Bir nesneyi Aslı ihtiyacı
yoktur ama bazen gelebilir bir örnek
verelim zengin şarkı söylemek Sizin yine
Düzenli bir fiil Eğer yani o içinde
örnek verelim erzingan litedb Aydın yine
Düzenli bir fiil ama e harfi kaynaştırma
olarak gelmiş buna dikkat edin kaydın
dukay test
bu fotografi yakın fotoğraf çekmek yine
Düzenli iş foto kafi yağı sakın örgü
örmek ama örgü kelimesini ihtiyaç yok iş
iş takı aynı yakı aynı yaka demezseniz
de yeni örgü gördüğünüz ifade etmiş
olursunuz iştahı aynı yakın
da tam seensey Yani onlar dikin da
tanısın lazım düzensiz bir fiil burada
sen ve o olan kısımları dikkat edin
Burada iyi harfi gelmiş bişe Listen bu
Bir de zaman fiili var zamen biriktirme
koleksiyon yapmak hemen fiil-çekimli Bir
bakalım iş zambırlı yerine İslam'la da
diyebilirsiniz daha pratik ve daha
kullanışlı olur e harfi düşebilir nelere
biriktiririz şuppi toygu zaviye than
Life Mike ın post Kağıt ınstyle Bunlar
kelimelerin çoğul halleri koleksiyon aç
olayları kullanır Çünkü örnek verelim iş
zamlı müsün
ve tuz Amed post kağıdın Hobi olarak
nasıl ifade ederiz My Hobby EST Kütahya
zammın zaman fiiliyle mastar halde en
sona geldi ve koleksiyonunu yaptığımız
ne sitemizde Onun önüne geldim ay Hobby
espit soygaz zaman mayın hobi zafiyetin
zaman gibi gelin ki gitmek ya da yürümek
demek biz burada gitmek fiile
uğraşacağız bakalım kim filmini Düzenli
bir fiil bu he nereye gidelim ins Kino
sinemaya bunu bu şekilde ezberleyin ins
Kino Eşkiya ins Kino içkiye insti ata
ata bir işi bir faaliyeti yapmaya da
gidebiliriz mesela dans etmeye
gidebiliriz iki tane fiil olduğu zaman
sadece bir fiil çekilir de diğer fiil
Sağ olun halde mastar halde çekilmeden
en sona yerleştirilir bu her zaman için
böyledir İş GYO tensın burada Gelin
filmi çektim diğer fili çekmedim işte ya
Ama ben tensın ya da yüzmek yüzmeye
gidelim işkey aşure mı niş ki yağı
Morgan svante film izin arkasında bir
sihirli kelime var ki o gelirse Bu
fiilin severek yaptığımızı ya da
sevmeyerek yaptığımız ifade etmiş oluruz
Ben katılamazsınız dırgan miskon gen ve
gene aynı şeylerdir İkisinden birisini
kullanabilirsiniz örnek verelim
bu Örneğin düz bir cümle yazalım işte
nsı ben dans ediyorum işten si şimdi
fiilin arkasına gelsin işten sık en dans
etmeye bayılırım dans etmeyi severim ya
da sevmeyelim işten Son işgen Dans
etmeyi sevmem unutmayın fiilin arkasına
getirin ve bu kelime değişmez çekimi
uğramaz son baş bir yani Örnek soru ve
cevap verelim sizinle brevas masto
indema Fight mahın yapmak demek yani Boş
zamanında ne yapıyorsun was mahsu
internete Fatih saat sistem sugeno
sadece şekilde cevap verebilirsiniz dans
etmeyi severim işten sa gene bi en
manası kaç saat tam sıiş beyanı basista
in hobi işbirliği Şah Ya da My hobbyist
Şah shoepi
bu çoğul olarak da sorulabilir hobilerin
nelerdir bas sindhind Oho Biz burada is
yerinizin dolmuş Çünkü çoğu cümle hobi
de çoğul haliyle hobis şeklinde
kullanılmış basit cevap verebiliriz iş
takı on zenga Game My hobi scents tycoon
10 zengin Tekke'de is çoğu dazin
kullanmayı unutmayın dersimiz sona erdi
ve aynı Hobbit sundu huf moths hav Sen
liptak nikmet su abartının hobisine
meslek haline getiren hayatı boyunca
çalışmak zorunda kalmaz PDF dosyası
ekledim onu indirip çalışabilirsiniz
Yine oyun ileri üzerinden alıştırma
yapabilirsiniz Bir sonraki derste
görüşmek üzere hoşçakalın